[Music]
ruby a dynamic interpreted scripting
language made famous for taking
simplicity and code readability to the
extreme it was first conceived by
yukihiro matsumoto aka mats in 1993 as
an easy-to-use scripting language like
python but with genuine object-oriented
features like smalltalk it exploded in
popularity after david hanemeyer hansen
aka dhh created rails in 2005 a model
view controller framework at the time it
was a game changer for startups because
it reduced the complexity required to
build a full stack web application and
has been used to build unicorns like
twitter shopify github and airbnb just
to name a few ruby is often called a
programmer's best friend thanks to its
minimal syntax that relies on plain
english words and the use of blocks to
write concise functional code at the
same time it's a true object-oriented
language where everything is an object
and every object can be modified giving
developers the flexibility to extend or
modify the behavior of the underlying
language the developer ecosystem is
large and mature code is shared between
developers with the rubygems package
manager where a program is organized
into a self-contained format called a
gem to get started install ruby then
create a file ending in rb to declare a
local variable give it a name followed
by a value there's no variable keyword
but you can define constants in all caps
or global variables with a dollar sign
every value is an instance of an object
which means we can call methods directly
on a string like so and parentheses are
usually optional ruby is dynamically
typed which means there's no type
annotations however modern tools like
rbs can add a type system on top of it
kind of like how typescript does for
javascript now to print a value to the
standard output use the puts method we
can define our own custom methods using
the def keyword which end with the end
keyword every method will always return
exactly one object no return keyword is
necessary or if you don't want a named
method you might create a block with a
do keyword which works like an anonymous
function blocks can also take arguments
found in between the pipe characters now
use the class keyword to create
blueprints for your own custom objects
an interesting point is that ruby
supports duct typing which means that if
it walks like a duck and quacks like a
duck then it's a duck in other words it
won't throw type errors based on the
class itself but rather the methods that
are implemented on it define the
initialize method to run code when a new
object is constructed any variable that
starts with at belongs to an object
instance while any variable with a
double at is static and belongs to the
class itself you can easily add getters
and setters to a class using the
attribute accessor method and now we can
create a new object instance by calling
the new method on the class now run your
code with the ruby interpreter from the
terminal this has been ruby in 100
seconds hit the like button and
subscribe if you want to see more short
videos like this thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one